my name's comic I'm in for like four
years ago in Seattle we were doing a
competition
I think Simpson thank you guys for being
here and planets on skin I have a lot of
confidence right now thank you
so you got you just like relax trust me
a lot of thing I think confidence is
very important to have because without
confidence stupid people would have no
idea those are called elections I am
actually a little bit nervous to be here
I'm not a big fan of crowds crowds my
least favorite thing next two
individuals individuals
I am actually Asian so I dare considered
confidence to be a social faux pas try
being a part of the High Line a little
comedy but sometimes I wish I was a
painter because never been painting a
picture at the campus be like I live in
a band full time the reason why I live
in a van is so I can pursue comedy so if
you didn't think I was funny
sorry not living your band funny hitter
written that joke in an apartment I
started dating inside a van today you
get them in there and it's really it's
all about the bush
I didn't know man
so you like even because well what you
said was happening is we go for a drive
it's all I can work up the courage other
we ever I have 45 minutes ago what do
you like to do
the reason ivanov and is so financially
i don't have to do anything that I don't
want to do except live in a bit stop to
do that part for the kitchen I woke up
today and I was like I wonder what the
temperature outside is like it was like
probably exactly the same was the
temperature inside this paint on my body
[Music]
van life and life is great I love dating
you know dating is pretty hard I stayed
a woman would leave to yoga and Chuck
steps and I was like do you enjoy
breathing or not I am Asian friend a
destination and which is very difficult
because they're both things they should
women are beautiful but not our
motivation and are very beautiful which
doesn't make sense because how you
negation women have created hey buddy
a future part of the sex process please
some kind of scampi the innocence of
being our children will be very
beautiful I am single I've yet to meet
my soulmate
I'm beginning to name maybe it's not
policies get out more my friends are
always like months you know learn how to
talk to women maybe or maybe women learn
to listen to on why don't try to hear
about the Federal Reserve
the party I was talking to a lady wants
it she was like did you know that my
vagina is that doing it because it can
make a baby and I was like that is it
correct your vagina is the trick
[Music]
there's not even a very good dirty
picture only prints one thing with lots
of errors 9 months the printers printing
is complaining the Avensis in advance
any trade is that I love the ladies you
know I think they're gonna take my women
give birth I feel like if an apron feel
like grow I'm going to be so much
protein and creatine this baby's like 27
[Laughter]
36 am I
public dude we're so lucky you went on
again you man
the gender we were attracted to was an
attractive to us back I was like what
the magic is right not only those people
I don't understand people would use the
Bible to be homophobic they'll say
Tammany and I had a bit Steve but other
people weren't even a good couple
vividly first of all it is a big God and
they did prove they weren't supposed to
eat which is f gay there is canon Abel
and Cain burger table now everything a
parenting advice for people who raise it
murderer only three other people on
earth because I used to be a Christian
as an Asian person we just have a weird
age being a Christian because the people
with the Bible didn't know that Asians
existed draw the saliva patients which
I'm on the fire words
my sister was a very big Christian I
said what would Jesus do bracelet and it
is very funny to me and they're very
rarely soccer behaving like a Jewish
carpenter you're an Asian woman
the first I'll speak Hebrew she just got
back from a mission trip which is what
Americans but if they're both countries
to get new profile pictures I am NOT a
Christian anymore because I'm an atheist
I'm a this because I'm not a
kindergarten and have an internet
connection
[Laughter]
stressful term an ideology that could be
destroyed by facts I I like to eat
General Tso's chicken
Indonesian man and my other Asian
friends they think fund me they're like
pump is it General Tso's chicken is
shady in America there's nothing
authentically agent like yeah but so
money
my favorite movies not showing every
Chinese province china called South
Korea promise it's not easy being a
minority I've experienced a lot of
racism
most people who race don't even realize
that they are okay this one egg hotels
means like Tokyo which of UNICEF as I do
your services this doesn't look like
this this may sweep your ching chong
language but because another culture
will be some of some people some people
like the dog okay
and people talk about that which I
understand is an American doctor
tingling family members but in Asia we
feed our family members like
[Music]
[Music]
what is our movie on words of Asian
yellow Panda
I don't like to be racist but I was
little playing once and I saw dude you
know put the Arabic which I'm a big fan
but then it's unfold the corner of the
page
[Laughter]
rednecks rednecks are pretty cool people
because they could survive in any world
in this situation that you put them in
accept a situation where everyone has
equal rights copacetic with a minority
if you have a white pride is a good
thing but a lot of people doing it
correctly like the Nazi to the
Confederate flag and everything Castle
so my friend this is racist he wants to
be racist as a family dentistry and I
think the Confederate flag is offensive
I think I put her a flat with white and
like 800 of time I'm going to thank you
darker man I try to divorce him yeah
super proud of the honey a boy and of
the person
but I'm gonna divorce papers tattooed on
my chest dating you know I not that into
anime but anyone who is sexually
attracted to be is privy to animes and
put all that interesting anime trace
[Laughter]
nozzoli phallus playing I'm on a date
like oh I'm eight bosses two bosses I am
of immigrants I think they're great and
talking to immigrants is the worst okay
they're always like go play around when
a job stops when you read it's like okay
um that is your real name I understand
people who blame arrogance to their
problems that like you knows taking all
my money it's people less money
what about the people with the money
I think capitalism is great if you want
to do it but it don't make everyone play
stupid game I like my grandma places
I like how Americans will say talking
ISM never works as if we didn't spend
billions of dollars and kill millions of
people to make sure it wouldn't work
Vietnam Tommy doesn't never works
whatever people control the means of
production their democratically elected
leaders mysteriously died and a small
rubber group always finds an automatic
weapons but I do support any policies
that Republicans consider communism
which is whenever two or more people
gathered to do something nice takes a
strange
I understand all the states in America
and they say prison don't drop the soap
that's not helpful
don't pick up the soap okay promise
myself as you want the bending over was
really get you even if you don't know
the soap you still gonna get raised you
just kind of really clean hands lon
mountains where these prisoners like man
I want to get that kid but it never not
to so
all right thanks very much
[Applause]